[موسيقى]
كيف تعرف أن لديك مشكلة
وأنك بحاجة إلى التخلص من السموم الرقمي جيدًا إذا كنت
تشاهد هذا الآن ، فأنت على الأرجح
خبير في التكنولوجيا ، فلديك الكثير من
الأجهزة المختلفة وقد تكون
شخصًا بحاجة إلى
التخلص من السموم الرقمي عندما تبدأ هذه الأجهزة في
التحكم في حياتك بدلاً من
جعلها أسهل في المنطقة التي نجد أن
هذا يؤثر على حياتك أكثر
وقد يفاجئك هذا ولكن في الحقيقة أن
نومك
ابحث عن الأشخاص الذين يستخدمون
أجهزتهم في مكان قريب جدًا  حتى وقت النوم ،
فإنه يخلق إثارة في دماغك
عميقة جدًا بحيث تجعل من
الصعب عليك الذهاب إلى النوم
، كما أنه يؤثر على إيقاعك اليومي
بشكل عام ، وهذا هو نوع
الإيقاع الطبيعي بين الأضواء والليل ،
وعندما يتعطل ذلك ، فإنه
يتلاشى  جدول نومك بالكامل
جيدًا شيء واحد لا تدركه هو أنه
ببساطة من خلال قراءة بريد إلكتروني أو قراءة
رسالة نصية في منتصف
الليل يمكن أن يأخذ عقلك من الصفر إلى 60
بسرعة كبيرة جدًا.  يعتبر دماغ القبعة
عقلًا صعبًا للغاية لإبطائه ، ومن
القواعد الجيدة عمومًا عدم التحقق
من الهاتف بالتأكيد في غرفة النوم أو
حول السرير قبل الذهاب للنوم.
استيقظ عن
طريق الهاتف أو عن طريق أي شيء آخر
وأنت مستيقظ وتجول
ولا تعود واستلقي على السرير
حتى تكون مستعدًا حقًا للنوم ، لذا
خذ قسطًا من الراحة
وضعيه خارج المكتب  ضع
الهاتف الخلوي بعيدًا ، فقد يساعدك على العيش حتى
مائة عام